关于外语学习
有这样一些广为流传的说法
第一要想讲出流利的外语
大胆练习对话是关键
第二听说读写输入输出同等重要
要同时进行
第三牢记语法
词汇是第一要义
学习要以质量为先
第四语学习即便困难
无惧成功
贵在坚持
那么这些说法是否正确呢
如果你认同其中的一条或者多条
可以把序号打在弹幕里
我是罗肖尼
这个视频是我数学研究和整理的结果
我会同学术案例
科学理论实操
建议个人经验
这四个方面来系统性的回答这些问题
我相信在看完全篇之后
你对语言学习原理和方法的认知将会彻底改变
但在那之前
我们先从一个故事开始讲起
一
974年
一个日本小女孩与托米
随着他的家人来到纽约
由于附近的工作调动关系
这个日本家庭将在美国暂住一年左右的时间
以聪明才四岁
在来美国之前
他没有学过英语
甚至连英文字母表都不会
非常幸运的是
这个日本家庭的邻居
刚好是一名著名的语言学家
Dr stephen crash
一位上世纪80年代
在语言学和语言教育领域掀起革命的人物
rain教授主动提出要帮助以聪明小可爱学会英语
和每个人一样
crash教授那时候认为
要让人学会英语
一定要让他多讲英语
So i try to get her to talk
I'd say he told me
Talk to me
Say good morning
Say hi
No response
CLASSI教授又说
你told me say ball
You told me
还是没有反应
从那时候到现在
人们都普遍相信
小孩子一般不会主动学习语言
除非你逼迫他们
所以crash教授又说
I won't give you
The ball
Until you say ball again
No response
认识he told me
没有一点反应
不管CRYIN教授说什么
做什么
与TOMMY都没有说过一句英语
他第一周没有说过一句话
第二周没有说过一句话
第一个月第二个月都没有说过一句话
直到五个月过后
一聪明才真正开口讲了英语
CARSON教授此时惊讶地发现
你TM1旦开口讲英语
就展现出了两个明显的特点
First it looked a lot like for language
Acquisition
The same process
Our children went through one word
Two words
Gradually getting more complicated
Second it came quickly by the time
He tommy and her family went back to japan
At the end of the year
Her english was closing in on the way
The other children in neighborhood were talking
那么问题来了
你托米沉默不语的五个月时间里面
到底发生了什么
可以让他某天突然开始讲英语
并且迅速从零进步到同龄小孩的水平呢
答案很简单
She was listening
He told me
在聆听你
Told me was listening
而在她那安静的聆听之中
可能包含着人类语音学习的最重要的秘密
为什么在crash教授的威逼利诱之下
一聪明小可爱一句英语都不说
但是过了五个月之后却自己慢慢开口了呢
因为以TOMMY在聆听
他在从周遭的语言环境中获取可理解的输入
Comprehensible input
She was listening
She was picking out
Comprehensible input
每当他通过语境
表情事物等等因素理解一句话的含义的时候
他就在自己的潜意识中积累了一点语言
而当这样的可理解输入
达到了几百几千个小时的数量级
以told me将在潜意识中积累足量的语言素材
而此时他将会自然地开口
和周遭的人用英语进行互动
这就是clash教授于80年代提出的
颠覆性的可理解输入假说
Comprehensible input hypothesis
当我们理解外语输入的内容的时候
我们会在潜意识中习得acquire外语
也就是通过听力和阅读两种输入
习得词汇
语音语法拼写作
所有的能力
对任何一个最终达到流利的语言学习者
大量的可理解输入都是一条必经之路
更重要的是
这个假说同时适用于母语和外语习得
并且无视年龄
语言天赋等个人因素
也就是说
即便你是语言天才
也必须要经过海量的可理解输入
才可以达到流利
关于这个问题
上一期视频输入假说有更详细的讨论
总而言之
以TOMMY初学英语的前五个月里面
一言不发
完全不代表着他有什么性格
或者学习能力上的缺陷
恰恰相反
ETI所经历的可能是最自然
最健康的语言系的过程
When she started to speak
It was not the beginning of her language
Acquisition
It was the result of all the comprehensible input it
She had gotten over those five months
让我再重复一遍
你聪明在五个月沉默之后所讲的英语
这并不是他口语练习的开始而已
经是他大量听力输入的结果
而那刚开始的五个月被语言学家称作静默期
塞恩period
任何人数学外语都会经历几个月到几年不等的
几乎无法用外语进行基础交流的阶段
很多语言学家将这个称为沉默期赛文period
在这个时段
学习者尚未通过听力和阅读
积累足量的可理解输入
也没有足够的自信在对话中使用外语
所以此时不能开口讲外语是正常的
也是正确的
但是人们往往不这样认为
要说好外语
就要尽早开口多讲外语
这是我们从小听到大的mantra
老师们也会以这个理由
在课堂上开展声势浩大的上台练口语环节
这就有点像一个萌新rapper
连韵脚都还没积累几个
就要在新说唱直播现场来一段freestyle
Freestyle
Go ahead
Marshall
Okay
Years ago
They try to years ago
They try to put me in the
是不是像极了雅思考官面前
一句话都说不出来的
你实际上与可理解输入假说相对的
需要假说
你害怕死
认为在极端需要的环境下
仍可以被逼迫学会并且输出目标语言
但是crush教授对此持反对意见
They say we're going to teach this guy
German
And we're gonna use the hypothesis
So they take this guy
And they say you're coming up with us in an helicopter
Without a parachute
And they put a gun to the guy's head
And they say
If you don't start to speak german now
We're gonna push you out of the helicopter
This is the need hypothesis
And the guy pursus
Oh it's kanye scotch buy became to scene on
You know
No cannot work
Okay
JE有趣的是
需要假说
似乎是很多人的共识
只要把你放在国内
你就会学会外语
只要报名了托福雅思
我就一定会有动力去进步了
这些说法
汽车和直升机学德语的故事
没有什么本质的区别
对至少对于初学者来说
输出带来进步的观点是不合理的
其实这是个很简单的道理
如果你没有听过读过正确的语言
那么你也说不出
写不出正确的语言
科学家认为
在沉默期开口讲外语可能只有一个真正的功能
那就是NOVA帮助你知道意识到自己的语言不足
When you speak
And you stumble and struggle
Then it also helps you notice now
If you write notice that you haven't got the words
If you speak you notice that you haven't got the words
也就是说初学英语的
你去找外国人聊天
去英语角互动只会有一个作用
To make you understand ups
即便你觉得练习口语取得了进步
这也并不是来源于你自己所讲的英语
而是来源于从对方那里听来的正确的英语
I'm not opposed to speaking
I think when student speak
But accounts and speaking is not what you say
But what the other person says to you
What counts is the input that you can stimulate from other people
So i'm in favor of students speaking
But we have to understand it
Makes an indirect
I helpful
But under our contribution to language
Acquisition
这就是为什么你不可能单纯靠说达到流利
在你能够说之前
你需要先让语言进入你的脑子
I say you can't speak your way to fluence
You have to get it in you
And you spent a lot of time listening
And if you don't like to read
That's too
Breading is also very very effective
总而言之
如果你还处于沉默期
并且不太能够开口讲话
这是非常正常
也是很正确的
所以回到开头的第一个说法
要想讲出流利的外语
大胆练习对话是关键吗
错误
每个人在学习外语时都会经历静默期
没有人可以在获得足够的语言之前
就说出流利的语言
我们绝不是说
在沉默期中的学习者应该被禁止说外语
如果你很幸运的拥有便利的语言环境
或者就是想把每一天学到的新表达马上用起来
那没有任何问题
成功的案例也是有的
我们也看到过
有多余者从接触外语的第一天开始
就积极地进行外语对话
并且最终也达到了很高的水平
但是我们相信
这需要学习者有充足的时间和便利的语言环境
对于更多人来说
过早开口讲话
不但无助于口语进步
而且会带来不好的后果
那就是语言石化
Fossilization
实话的观点有
SLINKER在70年代正式提出
这个理论
是指语言学习者因为缺乏正确而优质的输入
提早开口讲外语
而逐渐将外语中的一些错误形式固化了下来
从而一直停留在某个语言水平的现象
哪个学钢琴的孩子都会知道
如果把错误的手型或者指法练1000遍
固定了错误的习惯
那么曝光会影响远期的发展潜力
花很多力气可能也改不回来
甚至还有伤害手的危险
接下来是我们最喜欢的对号入座环节
在漏屋老师的二语习的文集
找对英语学习方法的第一本书里面
他提到语言石化可能会有几种层次
最低水平的实话是指
只能用最简单词汇进行交流
并且几乎说不出任何完整的句子
一般来说
低水平石化的同学都陷入了这样一个恶性循环
因为缺乏足量的输入
始终现在静默期中想练口语
但一开口发现了
几乎什么都说不出
竟然觉得口语练得还不够多
于是再逼迫自己开口练习
如此往复
直到数年不见进步
而最终悲惨的得出结论
我就是没有学习语言的天赋
然后从此放弃外语学习
鉴于这一层次的同学们
始终处于像婴儿一样牙牙学语的状态
我给他们取名牙牙人哦
第二层次的语言石化
则是只能够进行基本简单对话
但是绘画能力高度依赖于对话题的熟悉程度
并且大部分的语句都有明显的语法错误
这部分人的比例可能相对较高
典型的代表是秀水街的卖家大妈
How much you give me your best friend
Can you give me your best price
Yes
I give you
If you want to buy
If you don't want to buy
I don't wanna talk you
If you
Don't want to buy
I don't wanna see you
Don't wanna buy you ask me
不得不说
虽然大妈的口语十分简单
但是气场震撼
不过大妈使用英语的场景只限于秀水街
讨价还价
他需要掌握的词汇和表达也仅限于此
毕竟大妈不需要和雅思口语考官对
现
对于大部分这个层次的同学来说
他们的拼读输入仅限于新概念英语
一和二的部分课文
交流能力也只限于流利的在大街上问路
我给他们取名秀水街游魂五
第三层次语言石化的同学
经过多年挣扎
爱已经可以输出基本完整的语句
但是词汇范围局限
语言生硬
错误频出
他们的输入主要依靠考试而驱动
中高考托福雅思四六级
考研要考什么
他们就背什么
背完之后关上教材
这门语言就在与生活没有半点关联
殊不知
教材和考卷的输入不自然
不有趣
不足量
结果不管他们考几次
考十次
托福雅口语还是一样的结巴
语法还是一样的烂
最后分数也还是一样的
原地踏步
由于他们热衷于给各种考试机构
源源不断的输送报名费
我管它们叫做托福雅思慈善家
别往后看了没
在你家里装摄像头
五有趣的是
如果缺乏大量的可理解输入
即便身处国外的学习者
也会陷入语言石化的陷阱
我认知非常多的人上了课上了很多年
没有什么进步
在加拿大有了一个调查
有了几千个中国移民
7年差不多没有进步
虽然他们是向我们加拿大的excel
政府的安排
给英语的一些教英语的学生没有进步
所以这个上学校效率效率
我觉得比自己多听多阅读啊是低的
即便身处国外
这些学习者
也最多只掌握点菜和出行必备的语句
参加政府的英语课程
也是得过且过
因此不管他们在国外生活多少年
也仍然是不会外语的文盲
由此得名北美文盲哦
最后还有一种同学
他们的口语恐惧不完全来自于自己
而更多的来自于老师的口语纠错
PRESSION教授在日语系的园林实践中写到
很多初学语言
连1%的输入都还没有达到的学生
能讲的英语已经是非常的支离破碎了
还要在各种各样的口语交流训练里面挣扎着
让主语和谓语动词形式
并且还要时时提心吊胆
因为说错了一个词语
就会接受到老师的停班的口语纠错
真实吗
那single human being has a chance of getting to love
Speaking english with this experience
And we have reason to doubt this is
How many people gradually grow
A profound fear of the language
俗话说
黄金棍下出好人
但是在学习的领域应该是黄金棍下出哑巴
所以我们给这种同学起名叫做棍下哑巴
哦好了
我们的英雄集齐了
现在大家来选择自己的英雄吧
看到了吗
所有的英雄都有一个特点
牙牙人只有少量的单词短语输入秀水街游魂
只有部分生活场景的语言输入
托雅慈善家
只有考试是相关的材料输入
北美文盲和棍下哑巴也都将自己封闭起来
不再接收外界输入
只不过前者是因为满足于基本的生活用语
后者是因为语法纠错留下了长久的阴影
所有的哑巴英语英雄进化论都指向了一个结论
输入不足
尚处静默期的情况下
逼迫输出没有意义
甚至可能适得其反
海量的听和读才能带来流利的说和写
广听万家言
才能出语成文章
读书破万卷
方可下笔如有神
这是古人早就明白的道理
在我开始一个新能源
我多半的时间就用在听和音乐和宗教
我的词汇量开始习惯于听
这个也能够了解这个语言
很早的说话
关心我的发音这一类的东西
我一点都不管
在我学语言的时候听
像我整个这个时间的70%
当然这可绝不是说永远都不要开口讲话
不要把我说的话当成你永远不练口语的托词
我们一直在强调的是
不要搞错先后次序
不要过早地用强迫的方式练口语
如果你已经积累了几十上百个小时的输入
那么就像练习乐器一样
你不光要开口练习口语
你还要每天练习40个小时
关于练口语的一切
我都会在下期视频里详细讨论
But but before that i would say that the first thing in and improving your
Speaking ability and english
Any other language is to push your receptive skills
Push your passive
Knowle push the inpush
Just remember to push push and push your input
那么回到开头的第二个说法
听说读写输入输出同等重要
应该同时进行吗
错误输入在前
输出在后
你应该花七成的时间在听和读的输入上
而只花三成的时间在说和写的输出上颠倒
这个顺序可能会让你陷入语言石化的陷阱
所以说期待输出视频的小伙伴们
这次让你们失望了
填空题
把答案打在公屏上
因为我做这个视频
但是为了让大家知道
在语言习得中有三件事情最重要
那就是输入输入开始你妈的输入
青天大老一进步
左滚
理论完毕
这一部分只回答两个问题
听什么和怎么听
两个注意事项
第一这个视频中肖尼没有接商业推广
不拥有任何资料的版权
也不负责分发资源
第二上期视频就语法问题有详细的讨论
肖尼的B站专栏有制作详细的书单推荐
和本部分一起服用
首先是听什么
究竟何为可理解输入呢
上期视频也讲过
Comprehensible input
可理解输入有三个基本条件
有趣
interesting量大
Sufficient quality
最重要的是可理解
Comprehensible
或者叫A加一
A是你的语言水平
加一是指材料只比你的水平高一点点
初学者水平有限
能够选择的材料一般也就是无聊的初级教材
但是至少也要满足后两个条件
因此你要找的材料
第一是要带有transcript文字稿
文字稿可以帮助你快速的建立起
语音和文字的关系
从而提升材料的可理解程度
第二最好是要有难度分级的系列材料
这种材料有两个好处
Progression and repetition
循序渐进的难度设置
让你可以从适合自己水平的等级开始输入
并且可以清晰地知晓自己进步
其次作者往往会在一个系列的材料里面
有意无意地重复使用很多单词和短语
帮助你在多种情境下
熟悉这些语汇的含义和用法
据我所知
在这种情况下
单词的习得才会真正发生
关于单词习则可能会专门做一期视频来聊一聊
想看的可以打个一像这种语调重复一一个作者
一个系列或者一个门类的材料
被crush教授称作narrow input
狭窄范围输入
这对于初学者而言是至关重要的
江湖上流传已久的excel pot english part
就是满足以上要求的两套英语材料
我尤其喜欢english pod的精良制作和爆笑语境
如果难度适合你
非常推荐把这套材料拿来反复的听一听
但是两套材料的难度并不算低
对于从零开始的学习者
可能不算A加一
如果你愿意为优质的资源付钱
那么我非常推荐innovative language dot com
这个公司制作的系列podcast
从去年开始
我将他们的子网站japanese part one of one
dot com作为主力的输入来源
因为从absolute advance等级全包足够
我用的日语水平出师了
这家公司的英文版本
姊妹网站叫做english class
One on one dcom
需要的同学请自行去购买
小米本人不拥有版权
也不会进行资源的分发
当然如果你可以开动一点脑筋
那么即便是初级的阶段
你也可以在B站上找到很多有趣的东西
you dr.这样的儿童书作者
RAZ分级系列绘本或者神奇树屋系列
如果你想把阅读和听力结合在一起
那么还可以利用RELI视频
专门有人把著名儿童作家的作品
声情并茂的朗读出来
把画面和文字都帮你配置好了
比如说你完全可以沿着神奇树屋系列
一本一本的听下去
再不行
还有动画片啊
小猪佩奇
海绵宝宝的英文版本
都是非常非常好的入门选择
相信我哪怕是读完听完一本儿童图书
你获得的输入量可能也比读一整年教材更多
下一个问题是怎么听COFMAN老爷爷说过
内容为王
Content is king
如果你找到了难度适中
有趣量大的系列材料
那么理论上不管你怎么去使用它
都会产生不错的效果
但是为了诸位的方便
我把自己的方法分享出来
仅供参考
我的方法总结起来很简单
理解万岁
开心就好
假设你在使用english SPA作为输入材料
让我给你两条路来做选择
第一条是一生悬命学习路线
目标是把这套材料365期节目
每一期都吃透
包括正文对话
语法讲解
单词示例
不可以放过一条语法
一个单词
所以你一定要听一句停一句
一个小时吃不透就五个小时
一天吃不透就一周
一周吃不透就一个月
学语言不看质量
难道追求数量吗
在坚持了一周时间
硬啃了五期节目之后
你再一次在深深的自我怀疑中起了英语学习
第二条路线是理解万岁路线
因为你看了shy的视频
知道可理解输入的核心是comprehension
所以每一期节目都只听正文对话内容
发现查几个单词就能大致听懂故事
甚至还能哈哈的笑出来
其他语法讲解什么的
就去吃灰吧
每天花十几分钟
开开心心的过道
下一你就这样轻松愉快的养成了听english part的习惯
过了三四个月
你惊喜的发现
听不懂的句子逐渐变得清晰
很多单词逐渐变得熟悉
因为他们重复的出现
Narrow input anyone
这套材料你竟然不知不觉的听到了200多期
学语言不看数量
难道追求质量吗
那么问题来了
你选哪条路呢
在mason和rain教授的一篇研究中
学生们就被分成了理解万岁组合
一生学历
前者只用15分钟听老师讲外语故事
只以理解故事的内容为目的
而第二组则是用整整85分钟来听故事
讲单词
再加上几次考试
如你所料
在最后的结果中
一生学名著的学生有着略微更好的词汇
习的效果
但是他们花了理解万岁族五倍的时间
最后折算下来理解万岁组的词汇
习的效率是每分钟0.25个
比一生学命组要高出至少50%
更不用说一生悬命路线最大的问题是无聊
当死记硬背和考试成为了学习终点的时候
哪怕是世界上最生动的故事
也会失去它的趣味
这也就是为什么
绝大多数一生寻觅学习者们的热情
超不过三天半周
而以故事书为驱动的学生们
往往会培养起长久的输入习惯
所以说和大部分人的认知完全相反
对单词和语法的刻意学习与记忆
所谓的以质量为重
恰好是效率更低且更枯燥的路径
这个问题上期视频有更详细的讨论
你当然也可以把两条路线结合在一起
但是我在听读的时候主要走第二条路
首先我会尽量去寻找以故事为载体的输入材料
其次我会大量的读或者听我觉得有趣的内容
比如japanese part的对话
部分语法和单词我偶尔也会看一看
但只会花10%左右的时间
这是因为非常反直觉的一个事实是
越投入到理解中的学习者
对于单词和语法的习得和掌握反而越牢固
越自然
同时我们所说的comprehension
是指你能够理解六道七成左右的内容
就已经足够好了
即便你现在不能完全理解
相信我
你慢慢会理解的
有时候你听不懂
这个没没关系
你所了解的和本来的意思可能有一些差别
这也不要紧
继续签合约
这些比较糊糊涂的一些地方会慢慢清楚
慢慢清楚
第二我相信重复可以带来熟练
至少对于初期而言
在刚开始学日语的时候
几乎每一期japanese part对话
我都会听个几十遍
有时候在电脑前对照着transcript来听
更多是在走路
等车
骑车等等各种时刻听
我也会专门花时间来跟读
模仿或者叫影子跟读shadowing
下期视频我会专门谈这个方法
在不断的重复和增量中
你的理解能力一定会逐渐进步
第三一切都要在目标语言中进行
不要依赖你的母语
因此如果你打算看视频学外语
请确保它没有中文字幕
最好有目标语言的字幕
顺便来看一个发生在西班牙的关于字幕的实验
受试者是一群以西班牙语为母语的大学生
他们的英语能力被评价为中等水平
Intermediate
大学生们被分为三组
分别在三种情况下观看英语电影
第一组没有字幕
第二组有英语字幕
第三组则有西班牙语
也就是受试者母语的字幕
结果在之后的英语听力测试中
依赖母语字幕的组获得的提升几乎为零
无字幕的组获得了7%左右的进步
效果最佳的则是有英语字幕的第二组
他们获得了17%左右的测试分数提升
这个时间告诉我们
如果你是至少中等水平的语言学习者
那么观看到有外语字幕的视频
可能会有助于增加听力能力什么
你说这年头很难找到只带有英语字幕的视频
那我教你一招
至少你要去找个双语字幕版本的视频
然后啊对对
那个屏幕太冷了啊
你说啥呢
屏幕那个屏幕啷个咯
我把那个进入烤了
那你说说苹果是要做啥子啊
我还说日语说鲑鱼说日语
哪个学日语要扣电影
脑子苹果哎呀
练不动那个小说的问题
我要注意长途等等
每天想精想怪我们
那如果你发现关掉中文字幕
就看不懂也听不懂了好了
别骗你自己了
这根本不是你的爱
加隐隐混
去找更简单的材料
哦对了
还有最后两个问题
我怎么知道自己有没有进步呢
以及要听到什么时候
我有一个不太寻常的回答
如果某一天
你突然在脑海中听到了这门外语的声音
那么你可能已经完成了一次飞跃
我管这个叫做语言而出
Language awar
如果你听过一首歌曲很多遍
那么这首歌曲可能时常会
不受控制地出现在你的脑海中
非常有趣的是
似乎在语言学习中也有这样的现象
在脑海中听到外语
我想可能是大量可理解输入的自然结果
I did a couple of books with lindlee
My first bdarin teacher
So i've been listening to the stories
And i've been listening to her reading
Them very slowly and carefully
Yeah
I've gone through it about you
Chapter about ten times
Now
The other day
I picked it up
I heard her voice in my head reading the store
The correct pronunciation is beginning to be
Acquired absorbed
And you know like when you think you have like that inner voice in your head and one day
I was like this voice
Is an english
And i was like this is tight
每当你保持一段时间的海量输入
你会发现自己脑中所听到的外语越来越多
越来越完整
从某一天开始
你会不自觉地将外语脱口而出
而根本无需思考
这么开始的不可啊
有bk的talking
你说的跟你马斯拉尼玛尼哄过本科的talking
阿里马斯内被很多人吹得神乎其神的
所谓外语思维就是这么简单
所以说如果你已经有过了语言耳虫的体验
那么恭喜你
你可能走在了正确的道路上
但是能够偶尔在脑海中听到外语
能够脱口而出
零星几句话还不够
还算不上真正的脱离了语言石化的陷阱
保持输入是永无止境的
所以说最后一个问题需要多久
根据mason开始教授多年的重复实验
听外语故事的方法
可以带来每分钟0.2到0.2
五个生词的习得效率
这意味着听力60~80个小时的故事
可以习得1000个词汇
200至250个小时可以习得3000个
以此类推
在另一篇研究中
每月读一个小时的分级读物和小说
受试者可以获得托业考试中0.73分的提升
三倍于英专学生的效率
在老托福考试中获得0.25分的提升
两倍于昂贵的备考课程效率
这意味着
只要持续快乐的听读一年的故事
将可能牢牢的掌握5000多个词汇
并且在两门考试中跨越性的提升
所以也难怪rain教授说
And it is the kiss of death for the total preparation industry
I'm sorry
We have to go with what works
I'd rather the authors of graded readers
Make money on this
And not the total prep books people
Okay
至此语音学习的路线图已经向大家介绍完毕
但是还有一件很重要的事情
女友说还记得可理解输入三个条件中的有趣吗
没错要继续在语言学习的道路上走下去
你要尽早离开无聊的给初学者制作的材料
尽早的去寻找
让自己全情热爱
可以触及灵魂
让你进入心流状态的材料
我会告诉你
如果你真的有心有动力
整个世界都将是你的有趣的
可理解
输入
认识rich brian吗
她是来自印度尼西亚的
2020年全民说唱男朋友
BRYAN最著名的故事除了创作那首smoking fire的D
外界帮助的条件下
仅仅通过看海量的YOUTUBE视频
学会了流利的英语
You learn english through watching youtube
How much youtube were you watching this single day
It could be any video is not like videos of people
Ashley
Teaching english
Could be like you
Video
Like a boxing videos or like video games walk
Please do whatever
But so i used to play the rubiscube
And i used to watch a lot of tutorials
How to play the rubiscube
All the tutorials were in english
So that kind of got me used to that
And then at one point
I was thinking about something
And then i realized
I was thinking in english
Basically
I realized
And i was like
Oh that's really cool
I want to keep learning it
因为喜欢魔方游戏
嘻哈音乐
鸡哥的每一天都泡在了各种各样的YOUTUBE视频上
这样他逐渐喜欢上英语
并且最终用这门语言
写出了自己所有的说唱作品
This is so very epic
这让我想起了一个小伙伴在评论区的留言
不要学英语
用英语去学习你喜欢的东西
这个说法绝对不是陈腔滥调
他可能是学好任何语言的关键
之前的视频提过affective future
情绪滤网假说
任何人学语言的时候
都会面临着与输入材料之间的一道过滤网
当你越喜欢你的进度材料
这道过滤网就会越弱
相同的时间里面你会得到更多的输入
而材料越无聊或者难度越大
这道滤网就会越密实
你花一个月可能也听不进去几个字
张信教授在很多篇论文中强调过
要真正习得一门语言
最为理想的情况就是
在极端有趣且难度适合的外语材料中
进入心流状态
Flow state
以至于忘记时间的存在
忘记你所读或听的是外语
你一定有个沉浸在看某部电影或者读博文
小说中
抬头猛然发现已经过去了许久的经历吧
无比神奇的是
当这种情况发生的时候
尽管你没有背单词或者分析语法
你的语言学习效率会达到顶峰
例如我高中毕业的暑假
开始阅读SIDNEYSHELDON爷爷的悬疑小说系列
一开始我还保持着每两页一个的频率查记单词
到了后面实在是太有趣了
我经常会读到坐车坐过站
三餐忘记吃的地步
一个暑假读完了十几本小说之后
我的词汇量和语言能力
已经在毫无意识中发生了几个层次的飞跃
沉浸在一本书中
甚至于忘记你在听或读外语
这是我们能想象的最理想学习状态
而要达到这种地步
你必须要找到适合自己难度
并且全身心热爱的东西
相比之下
从未学好过外语的人们几乎有着同样的说辞
我背单词已经足够痛苦了
你还让我去找有趣的东西来听来读
Guys
You totally misunderstood
This not being able to enjoy company
English is precisely
Why you never get to enjoy a master
The language
If i ask a hundred different polyglots
I heard a hundred different approaches to learning languages
The one we all have in common is that we simply found ways to
Enjoy the language learning process
You should have seen their faces
When they were showing me their colorful
Grandma charts
Carefully handmade flesh guard
And there's statistics about learning
Vocabulary using apps or even
How they love to cook based on recipes in a foreign language
All of them use different methods
But they always make sure
It's something that they personally enjoy
根据我的经验
如果我找到了自己全情热爱的东西
那么即便他对于我来说是A加二
甚至是I加N的难度
我也会突破情绪滤网的限制
非常有兴致地看下去
听下去
初中的时候
我偶然接触到了一台iPod touch
随即我被这台小小机器上面
石破天惊的创新所折服了
我对苹果公司和乔布斯产生了浓厚的兴趣
设法找到了乔布斯
从90年代开始的每一次产品发布会
从IPAD到Macbook care
从IPHONE到IPAD
我一次又一次的观看这期发布会
也似懂非懂的记下了我单词
顺便说一句
乔布斯是举世罕见的演讲大师和故事大师
我还从他的发布会中逐渐学会了storytelling的技巧
并且在各种场合中运用
当然也包括你们正在看的这个视频
这也是一种可理解输入
我认为storytelling是当今世界最稀缺的能力之一
之后一定会开一期或者多期视频
专门聊聊雪儿跳脸
想看的可以打第一
除此以外
兴趣还驱动着我
把哈利波特与魔法师的电影版拿出来
翻来覆去看了无数遍
直到台词都快背下来
高中听一个兄弟演唱EMINEM的lose yourself
随即喜欢上了嘻哈文化
又慢慢地将阿姆的束手金曲
生吞活剥地学了下来
并且到处演唱
我还看过英文版的海绵宝宝
无数的脱口秀和访谈节目
多亏了神奇的YOUTUBE
这一切都发生在我小小书房里的电脑上
和我那只有最简单功能的mp4播放器上
在看这些视频的时候
我几乎没有依赖过中文字幕
这倒也不是因为我故意不看中文字幕
关键是那个时候我想要搜索
带中文字幕的苹果发布会视频
找到的全部都是红富士苹果批发的广告
就这样
我将自己所有的时间铺到了
各种各样的有趣输入
上中学时期
英语老师们拿我最没有办法
这家伙也不听讲
整天在班级上树立坏榜样
但是他又总是能够考到不高不低
全班第二名
为什么他总是能精准的考了第二名
经过几年的自由生长
高三我裸考了第一次雅思口语得到了积分
高考前一个月左右
我开始发力
集中练习高考题目
最后高考英语得到了142分
进入大学之后
我开始广读英文贤书
参加演讲比赛
这些帮助我大二的时候
雅思口语考取了8.5分
总分也是8.5分
最棒的是考取这些分数的过程中
备考和刷题从来不是我的主线
享受英语才是
I only realize this after meeting other polyges
We are no geniuses
And we have no shortcut to learning languages
We simply found ways to turn language
Learning from a boring school
Subject into a plan activity
Which you don't mind doing every day
This is how polyglots learn languages
And the best news is it's available to anyone
Who's willing to take the learning into their own hands
So guys
Guys
Guys stop asking what material should i use
第一这个问题只有你自己一个人才能回答
You cannot outsource the task
Finding your hobby to anybody
but you第二
User imagination be more creative
你必须有主动性
你必须对这个新的语言
新的文化有好去找新的东西来听蓝月
你必须得每天做得多主动
So do you like tech go watch on boxing videos
Are you going to make up and clothing
They're like a million
Makeup youtubers out there
You are gamer get yourself some game walk throughs
You were perfect that even hub is better than the big band theory
No no offense
I'm a big fan of tvt
But seriously
We even watch friends
Were the big bantheory with subtitles to learn english
Stop lying to yourself
Go get some authentic conferensible
Subtitle free input
如果说任何时候你感到语言学习困难或者乏味
Than something is definitely wrong
因为有趣的材料不是锦上添花
而是成功语音学习的必须有了趣味的加持
语言学家不再是一件需要的事情
至此四个说法被我们全部检验完毕
让我们对石碑做一下修改
流利的外语来自于听读
你能理解的材料
而不是对话练习
不要颠倒输入和输出的顺序
以免陷入石化陷阱
不要迷信记忆语法
词汇
海量和理解才是输入的关键
唯独有趣和热爱的内容
可以伴你走过漫漫语言学习的路途
最后请记住
在这个世界上有正确的学习原则
但是却没有一种万能的学习方法
或者适用于任何人的万能材料
你要做的就是基于正确的原则去试验
让自己进步的方法
去寻找让自己真正沉静的内容
又一次这个视频的研究和制作经历了十几稿
历时几个月
我尽量试图在理论性
趣味性和实用性中找一个平衡
也希望可以多一个人看到这里
并且带走一点与他有用的东西
还有很多人始终认为一定要去国外生活
才能学好外语
那有这样的条件当然是无比幸运的
但是我丝毫不相信
只有出国才能学好外语这句话
因为有太多太多的人
依靠自己的主动性和互联网的帮助
掌握了流利的外语
我也不例外
我第一次出国旅游是在高中2年级
在洛杉矶机场
和一个华人小哥用英文攀谈的时候
他异常惊讶地问我
围绕这句learn english
Did it back home in chong qing china
So you go to international school
Now
My school is called the internet
做英语学习者
我们是世界上最幸运的一批人
在广阔的英语世界里
我们永远不会缺乏适合自己难度的书籍
视频电影
因为互联网的便利
我们可以在家里和手机上
就连接到无穷无尽的内容
不得不承认
由于时间和意愿的不同
每个人最后能够达到的语言水平各异
但是科学告诉我们
只要走在了这条路上
任何人都可以度过沉默期
逃出语言石化的陷阱
并且最终达到流利
看完这个视频之后
请去找到一套适合自己的输入材料
放下一切对于方法和天赋的怀疑
用最少三个月时间去走完一次快乐的输入之旅
相信我只要经历过第一次
你就知道
外语世界的大门永远为你而开放
So what are you waiting for
感谢你能看到这里
如果喜欢这期视频
还请不要忘记给我点赞
投币收藏转发
去年的创作因为各种各样的原因而中断
让大家苦等
非常不好意思
但是现在我回来了
下期视频让我们6月再见
至少我希望如此牺牲
Thank you